j'ai de
qu'est-ce qu'il y a c'est Mathieu tu me
mets
[Rires]
toi ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pense qu'on a eu autant envie en
disant de quoi de ces tringler c'est
vrai ou pas moi plus de t'étrangler
beaucoup plus tu vois avec tes yeux
d'enfants qui me touche excusez-moi
est-ce que est-ce que quelqu'un pourrait
me remettre mon micro s'il vous plaît
c'est déjà trop long non franchement
j'ai déjà envie de partir non mais c'est
bon
là je te le dis vraiment mais c'est vous
regarde pardon je dis pas ça pour vous
mais vous voulez savoir quel sera la
tendance cheveux ou habits pour regarder
un gay vous serez si passe dans deux
mois
et donc
tu dois avoir des amis gays mais c'est
vrai que c'est je vous serez comment ça
sera dans deux mois
non mais ça y est ça va Sophie alors on
est venu avec la brocante
alors aujourd'hui on a les Caroline
magie rideau pour un magnifique
armoire fin 19e
le gay pendant 11 mois il libère il doit
être beau au mois d'août c'est ça la
coiffure pousse le corps et tout c'est
pour ça que c'est dégueulasse
2022 j'avais été raide de Mykonos et là
cette année je le remets en jeu donc je
suis ben oui
2019 et 2022 alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire pour être alors en fait tu vas
dans une boîte le soir
et tous les soirs tu danses tu machin tu
dragues tu ramènes des gens et il y a
les gens de la boîte qui note comment
tu danses comment tu es tenues
c'est vraiment je te raconte
et à la fin c'est minimum sur 10 jours
tu peux pas sur une semaine
de Mykonos qui a tout le monde qui est
là c'est génial et puis il y a des drag
queen allemand qui sont qu'est-ce qu'il
y a et draguer
jamais non mais dans quelle émission il
y a un gars qui rentre tranquille il
prend un papier non mais lui c'est une
barquette mais là exprès
et je vais te dire c'est toi qui a
raison dans quelle émission dans quelle
émission parce qu'on a l'antenne hein le
garantie pour un papier il passe à la
technicien qui vient
[Applaudissements]
appelle
on continue la mission fais ta vie ta
mère de pas
donc tu me disais non non mais fais
samedi il était pas là vas-y il fait sa
vie dignité non mais c'est vrai bravo tu
coupes une anecdote j'étais lancée
alors vas-y vas-y alors
qu'elle a dignité alors oui et donc à la
fin des 10 jours il y a tous les gars
sont là parce qu'ils veulent savoir
[Rires]
vraiment ouais
à 2h du matin il y a le vote qui tombe
non ça peut être des Allemands et tout
ça et moi je l'ai eu que alors j'ai été
parfois vice et tout et moi j'ai eu 2019
j'ai eu et 2022
[Rires]
il s'appelle Hugo tu peux lui dire merci
[Applaudissements]
en fait les jours qui suivent les gens
qui suivent mettez le roi là-bas
ça consiste en quoi être le roi du Rambo
à Mykonos ça veut dire que toute l'île
c'est petit
[Rires]
les Allemands
du coup à la plage on vient de voir
bravo pour votre titre
prenons un verre pour en parler et puis
voilà donc
cette émission
tu as deux chaussures différentes
[Rires]
et une autre chose tous les techniciens
t'emmerde
je pense que on peut faire alors on peut
venir mon chéri
on va faire un petit tour un petit
sondage euh Joe tu me confirmes tu
l'emmerdes mais tu es une force
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Mathieu Delormeau mon ordi la vérité
fortement voilà merci merci
Alexandre Alexandre
Alexandre
il est super Alexandre mon chéri tu me
confirmes-sur-mer Mathieu Delormeau au
nom de toute l'équipe oui
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes virés de TPMP
Jean-Michel
leur enfant cherchait plus proche vous
brûlez vous brûlez